>>> A FORMER DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE WENT
VIRAL WHEN SHEOSTED A FALSE
CLAIM ABOUT THE MORNING AFTER
PILL.
PAM KEITH TWEETED, QUOTE,
TENNESSEE JUST BANNED PLAN B AND
MADE IT A CRIME PUNISHABLE BY A
$50,000 FINE TO ORDER IT.
THE PROBLEM WITH IT, IT IS NOT
ACCURATE.
JOINING US NOW TO EXPLAIN, CNN
REPORTER DANIEL DALE WITH A FACT
CHECK.
DANIEL?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, TENNESSEE HAS
NOT BANNED PLAN B, PLAN B
CONTINUES TO BE AVAILABLE TO
TENNESSEE RESIDENTS THERE IS NO
FINE FOR ORDERING PLAN B.
THE VIRAL TWEET IS PLAIN
INACCURATE.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
LAST WEEK GOVERNOR BILL LEE OF
TENNESSEE SIGNEDED A NEW LAW
THAT INCREASES THE PENALTY FOR
SENDING PEOPLE IN TENNESSEE
ABORTION MEDICATION BY MAIL OR
COURIER.
MAKES THAT A FELONY WITH A FINE
OF UP TO $50,000.
UNDER BOTH PREVIOUS TENNESSEE
LAW AND THIS NEW LAW, DOCTORS
HAVE TO DISTRIBUTE ABORTION
MEDICATION TO PATIENTS IN PERSON
ONLY.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, JOHN, PLAN
B IS NOT ABORTION MEDICATION, IT
IS CALL THE MORNING AFTER PILL
FOR A REASON, IF PURPOSES
PREVENTING PREGNANCY NOT
TERMINATING PREGNANCY.
THE LANGUAGE OF THE NEW
TENNESSEE LAW MAKES CLEAR THAT
THIS RESTRICTION AND THE FINE
JUST DON'T COVER PLAN B AND
OTHER EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION AT
ALL.
SECOND, THE FINE OF UP TO
$50,000 IS FOR PEOPLE WHO
PROVIDE ABORTION PILLS BY MAIL,
COURIER OR DELIVERY.
AGAIN, TALKING ABORTION PILLS,
NOT PLAN B.
AND CRITICALLY, THE LAW
EXPLICITLY SAYS THAT PATIENTS
ARE EXEMPT FROM PENALTIES.
THE PENALTIES ARE FOR THE
PROVIDERS WHO BREAK THE LAW, NOT
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ORDER THE
MEDICATION.
NOW, MISS KEITH'S TWEET WAS UP
FOR A FEW DAYS, GOT MORE THAN
26,000 RETWEETS.
SHE DELETED IT AFTER I REACHED
HER BY PHONE YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
AND EXPLAINED THE LAW.
SHE SAID SHE NEVER CLAIMED TO BE
A DOCTOR, TO BE IN TENNESSEE OR
TO BE AN EXPERT IN NEW TENNESSEE
LAW.
BUT I DON'T KNOW, TWEET WAS
PRETTY DEFINITIVE SOUNDING AND
THIS SUBJECT IS SO PERSONAL THAT
INACCURATE CLAIMS CAN REALLY
AFFECT PEOPLE'S EMOTIONS AND
POSSIBLY THE LIFE DECISIONS THEY
MAKE.
ONE ABORTION RIGHTS GROUP IN
TENNESSEE TOLD ME THEY DECIDED
TO PUT OUT AN INSTAGRAM
STATEMENT CLARIFYING THAT THE
NEW LAW DOESN'T ACTUALLY CHANGE
MUCH FOR PEOPLE BECAUSE PEOPLE
THEY'RE IN TOUCH WITH WERE
TAKING IN MISINFORMATION AND
GETTING CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT THE
LAW ACTUALLY DOES.
>> NOT JUST GETTING THE TRUTH,
BUT GETTING RESULTS, DANIEL
DALE.
SO, LOOK, IF ROE IS STRUCK DOWN
BY THE SUPREME COURT, ABORTION
LAW WOULD BE SET BY EACH STATE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT
TENNESSEE'S POSSIBLE POST ROE
FUTURE?
>> IF ROE IS INVALIDATED,
TENNESSEE IS PLANNING TO BAN
ALMOST ALL ABORTIONS.
IT IS ONE OF MORE THAN A DOZEN
STATES THAT HAS SO-CALLED
TRIGGER LAW IN PLACE, A LAW THAT
SNAPS INTO EFFECT IF ROE IS
OVERTURNED AND THIS TRIGGER LAW
SAYS 30 DAYS AFTER ROE GOES
DOWN, ABORTION IS BANNED.
THERE IS AN EXCEPTION FOR THE
LIFE OF THE MOTHER, BUT NO
EXCEPTION FOR RAPE OR FOR
INCEST.
>> AND THAT HAPPENS 30 DAYS
AFTER ROE IS STRUCK DOWN.
DANIEL DALE, AS I SAID, NOT JUST
THE TRUTH, BUT RESULTS, THANKS
SO MUCH FOR THAT.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
>>> LET'S BRING IN CNN CHIEF
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT DANA
BASH, AND CNN CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT KAITLAN COLLINS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING SENATOR TED CRUZ SAID
THERE ARE SOME IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHO ARE NERVOUS ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF OVERTURNING ROE
V. WADE.
>> I CAN TELL YOU DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON ARE HOLDING ON TO
THAT AS THEIR HAIL MARY CHANCE
TO SAVE THE MIDTERMS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE WILL BE
HORRIFIED AND THAT WILL HELP
THEM WIN.
AND I GOT TO TELL YOU, MORE THAN
A FEW REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARE
NERVOUS THAT'S THE CASE.
>> WE KNEW THIS, BUT IT IS SO
INTERESTING TO HEAR HIM SAY IT.
>> IT IS.
HE ALSO SAID IN THAT SAME
PODCAST, I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A POSITIVE EFFECT OF PEOPLE
IN THE PRO LIFE COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR THIS FOR
50 YEARS.
HE MIGHT BE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
BUT IF HISTORY IS ANY GUIDE FOR
US HERE ON THE WAY POLITICS AND
POLITICAL MOVEMENTS AND FERVOR
WORKS, IT IS NOT ON THE SIDE OF
THE VICTOR, AND IN THIS CASE
POLITICALLY SPEAKING THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR 50 YEARS,
SINCE ROE FIRST WAS -- HAPPENED
IN THE EARLY '70s.
NOW THE QUESTION REALLY IS ABOUT
HOW MUCH OF A GALVANIZER THIS IS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE,
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE TAKEN FOR
GRANTED THAT THIS WOULD JUST BE
THE LAW OF THE LAND FOREVER.
AGAIN, HISTORY TELLS US THAT
THAT IS WHERE THE ENERGY IS MORE
LIKELY TO BE.
NOT ON THE SIDE OF THOSE WHO --
WHOSE ENERGY FOR 50 YEARS PAID
OFF.
>> THIS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES HAVE
WANTED TO SEE FOR SO LONG.
IT HAS BEEN ONE OF THEIR
DEFINING PRINCIPLES.
MAYBE IT ANIMATES THE BASE, BUT
NOT THE SWING VOTERS WHO ARE
HESITANT ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, HAD THIS RULING HAPPENING,
THIS COMING DOWN, WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE FUTURE OF THAT.
THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERN FROM
SOME OF THESE REPUBLICAN
SENATORS COMES FROM.
>> ONE THING THAT IS IMPORTANT,
BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING INTO THE
NITTY-GRITTY OF THE MIDTERMS,
THERE IS SUCH A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
AND THE DYNAMICS THAT COULD PLAY
OUT WITH THIS AND OTHER ISSUES.
THERE IS SO FEW SWING DISTRICTS
LEFT IN THE HOUSE BECAUSE OF
REDISTRICTING AND LOTS OF OTHER
REASONS THAT THE POOL OF
POLITICIANS FOR WHOM THIS COULD
MAKE A MAKE OR BREAK DIFFERENCE
IS SMALL.
ON THE SENATE SIDE, YOU HAVE
LARGE STATES, YOU HAVE LOTS OF
SUBURBAN POCKETS, LOTS OF
POCKETS WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENERGIZED COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> WHEN WE COVERED CONGRESS
TOGETHER, THERE WERE SO MANY
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE, YOU ANY,
PRO-LIFE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY,
BECAUSE HERE IN A FEW HOURS
WE'RE GOING TO SEE PRESIDENT
BIDEN GIVING A SPEECH ADDRESS
INFLATION.
THERE ARE SO MANY AMERICANS SOUR
ON THE ECONOMY.
WHAT DO WE EXPECT HE'S GOING TO
SAY?
>> THE THING IS, IT IS THE FACT
HE'S GIVING THIS SPEECH, THAT HE
FEELS THE NEED TO COME OUT TO
ADDRESS THIS, TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
HIS GAME PLAN IS, WHEN YOU HEAR
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE LIMITS TO WHAT
HE CAN DO TO TRY TO BLUNT THIS.
BUT THEY SAY THEY KNOW HE HAS TO
BE OUT THERE TALKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THEY WANT
TO SHOW HE IS ADDRESSING IT,
BECAUSE FOR ALL THE TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE
SUPREME COURT RULING, ONE THING
WE DO KNOW IS RIGHT NOW THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN THAT VOTERS
HAVE IS INFLATION.
AND THE ECONOMY.
AND THEY DON'T THINK IT IS GOING
WELL.
AND SO YOU'LL SEE PRESIDENT
BIDEN COME OUT AND TALK ABOUT HE
HAS DONE SO FAR, WHAT HE PLANS
TO DO, BUT LOOK AT THE REPORTS
THIS MORNING ABOUT GAS PRICES
REACHING A NEW HIGH.
GOING UP 17 CENTS JUST IN THE
LAST WEEK ALONE, IN THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS, AND THAT'S A MAJOR
CONCERN FOR THEM, BECAUSE, YES,
PRESIDENT BIDEN RELEASED OIL
FROM THE STRATEGIC RESERVES LAST
MONTH, PRICES DIPPED A LITTLE
BIT, AS WE SAID AT THE TIME, AS
WHAT ANALYSTS WERE TELLING US,
EXPERT OZ ON THIS MATTER, IT IS
GOING TO BE TEMPORARY AND
THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK UP.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING THAT,
YOU'RE HEARING CONCERNS ARE
GOING TO GO UP EVEN FURTHER THIS
SUMMER.
IT IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT IS GOING
AWAY FOR THEM.
THEY KNOW IT IS NUMBER ONE.
>> THEY'RE HEARING, I'M SURE
WHAT WE'RE BOTH HEARING, FROM
THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE ON THE
BALLOT, IN NOVEMBER, BEGGING THE
PRESIDENT TO GET MORE INVOLVED
ON THE ISSUE OF THE ECONOMY,
BEGGING HIM TO GET OUT MORE --
MORE OUT FRONT ON IT.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO SAY I CAN
RUN SEPARATELY, TRIANGULATE,
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
FOR THE MOST PART, THOSE RINNING
CAMPAIGNS SAY THE PRESIDENT IS
TIED TO THE ECONOMY.
>> DO YOU THINK RIGHT NOW IF WE
CAN SWITCH TOPICS AND TALK ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HOW THE WHITE
HOUSE, HOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
SEEN PUTIN AFTER THAT SPEECH HE
GAVE YESTERDAY ON A KEY DAY ON
VICTORY DAY, WHAT ARE THEY
THINKING NOW AFTER PUTIN REALLY
DIDN'T SAY WHAT THEY THOUGHT HE
MIGHT.
HE DIDN'T DECLARE VICTORY.
HE DIDN'T DO SOME SORT OF
VICTORY LAP OR ANYTHING.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING HE'S
GOING TO DO NOW?
>> THERE WAS A BIT OF A DIVIDED
VIEW IN THE WHITE HOUSE OF WHAT
YESTERDAY'S SPEECH FROM HIM WAS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
SOME SAID MAYBE HE WILL TRY TO
DECLARE VICTORY OR ANNOUNCE HE'S
MOBILIZING WORKFORCES.
OTHERS WERE SKEPTICAL GIVEN HE
DOESN'T HAVE PROGRESS TO TOUT AT
THIS SPEECH.
HE DIDN'T MAKE NEW ANNOUNCEMENTS
THERE.
THEY WATCHED IT VERY CLOSELY.
OFFICIALS FOUND IT SUBDUED,
MUTED, DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING NEW,
THEY DIDN'T FEEL THE NEED TO
RESPOND IN ANY GREAT WAY TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT HE SAID BECAUSE WHAT
IS THE POINT OF ESCALATING IT
ANY FURTHER.
ONE BIG QUESTION THAT I THINK
WAS REVEALED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN
LAST NIGHT, HE SAID AT A CLOSED
DOOR FUND-RAISER IS PUTIN IS A
VERY CALCULATING PERSON.
BUT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE HAVING
TROUBLE FIGURING OUT WHERE HE'S
GOING NEXT.
AND WHAT IS A POSSIBLE EXIT FOR
HIM HERE, AN ENDGAME WHERE HE
CAN SAY I HAVE THIS TANGIBLE
ACHIEVEMENT, THIS IS WHAT I'M
GOING TO HANG MY HAT ON IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DECLARE VICTORY IN
UKRAINE?
BECAUSE THINGS HAVE CHANGED SO
MUCH FROM HE WANTS TO TAKE THE
CAPITAL, THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NOW HE'S MOVED TO FOCUS ON
EASTERN AND SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
THE PROGRESS THERE FOR THE
RUSSIANS HAS BEEN INCREMENTAL AT
BEST WHEN YOU TALK TO PENTAGON
OFFICIALS.
NOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT, WHAT HE'S SAYING
IS I DON'T KNOW HOW HE GETS OUT
OF THIS WAR IS THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS THAT PUTIN FEELS LIKE
HE CAN TOUCH ON THAT HE CAN THEN
EXIT THIS WAR AND STILL FEEL
THAT HIS REPUTATION IS IN TACT.
AND YOU HEARD THE CIA DIRECTOR
SAY THIS, HE THINKS THAT RIGHT
NOW PUTIN'S MINDSET IS HE CANNOT
AFFORD TO LOSE THIS WAR.
>> WHICH IS WHAT HE DIDN'T
EXPECT, AND IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THE ANSWER IS THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
PUTIN AS THIS CHESS PLAYER, AS
SOMEBODY WHO IS PLAYING THE LONG
GAME WHO HAS A PLAN OUT FOR THE
FUTURE, THAT BECAUSE HIS
STRATEGY IN UKRAINE DIDN'T GO
THE WAY HE INTENDED, HE MIGHT
NOT KNOW THE ANSWER, SO
EVERYBODY IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
IS TRYING TO GET INSIDE HIS
HEAD, HIS HEAD MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE ANSWER WHERE HE WANTS TO GO
RIGHT NOW.
>> AND I THINK ONE CONCERN, WE
HAVE TRIED TO TALK ABOUT THIS IN
SUCH A MEASURED WAY BECAUSE IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU DO WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THIS THREAT OF
HIM USING A TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPON, THE THING I THINK STANDS
OUT THE MOST FOR ME, WHEN YOU
LISTEN TO THE CIA DIRECTOR AND
HE SAYS THE CHANCE ISN'T ZERO.
WE'RE NOT SAYING IT ISN'T GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE DON'T HAVE INTELLIGENCE HE'S
MOVING OR POSTURING TO MAKE A
STRIKE LIKE THAT, BUT THEY'RE
NOT SAYING IT IS A ZERO CHANCE,
HE IS CONDUCTING THIS NUCLEAR
SABER RATTLING, HIS AIDES ARE,
IT RAISES A CONCERN FOR PEOPLE
LIKE THE CIA DIRECTOR.
THAT IS SUCH AN INTERESTING
ASPECT OF THIS, AS I THINK THEIR
CONCERN IS HE GETS KIND OF TO
THE END OF HIS ROPE AND THAT'S A
LAST RESORT MEASURE.
>> MAYBE A SIGN OF HIS
DESPERATION, BUT DOESN'T MEAN
HE'S NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO DO
IT, IT ISN'T A SMALL CHANCE.
DANA AND KAITLAN, THANK YOU